sri lanka's defense minister says police
have arrested seven suspects believed to
be linked to the wave of bombings that
killed at least 190 people
the first seven blasts targeted churches
and luxury hotels
in and near the capital colombo a church
in the eastern town of batikalau was
also hit
one of the suspects was arrested on the
outskirts of colombo
at the scene of an eighth explosion that
killed three police
as they attempted to search a house most
of the casualties came from the church
bombings where worshipers were
celebrating easter
the prime minister of sri lanka ranil
wicker messenger has been speaking about
the attacks today
let's have a listen
i would like to express my condolences
with the families of victims
and those injured in the attacks that
took place in the country today
i see this as a major crisis that will
lead the country
and its economy towards instability
i strongly condemn these attacks that
targeted religious
sites and luxury hotels
all of us must uphold the law of the
land
let's cross over now to jamila najmudin
editor of news in asia and journalists
in colombo sri lanka
uh at least two more blasts followed the
earlier bombings today what's the
situation in
and around colombo now
yes hello so basically the latest
information
is that the security forces have
arrested
seven people in connection with the
eight blasts
which took place today and uh security
also has been beefed up
across the island especially in the
places of worship
and an island-wide curfew has been
imposed until further northeast
um do we have any information yet on the
suspects arrested
uh we do not have any information as to
which
organization these suspects belong to
because the police are not divulging
much to us
but we do know that two of the suspects
are currently
trapped in a house in the matagorda
where one of the explosions took place
and the police have surrounded the area
officials have imposed a social media
ban in sri lanka following the bombings
what's the aim of that so basically when
the
uh attacks to explosions took place
today morning
there was a lot of misinformation which
started coming out on social
media which expressed panic and fear
amongst the public
it was also igniting racism so just a
short while ago president michael farmer
citizen released a statement
urging people not to release false
information
which would create further pension in
the country
so the aim of this is basically to
spread misinformation we are traveling
out
this is of course an ongoing operation
you talked about panic in the streets
what's the situation
now well basically the streets are
deserted at the moment since there's a
curfew in place
until further notice and those who wish
to travel to the airport who have flight
are us to show their tickets in their
passports at all the security
checkpoints
so you do not see anybody on the roads
at the moment except for the triforces
um you talked about the curfew what
other measures are officials
implementing at the moment
so basically uh the police have been
dispatched outside all places of worship
across the island and also outside all
these star class hotels in colombo
and the rest of the country and there's
a search and rescue operation going on
by
by the authorities in all the explosion
sites
that is the only information which we
are hearing at the moment
sri lanka's christian community was hit
particularly hard by these bombings
during his easter mass in the vatican
pope francis
condemned the violence let's listen
i heard with sadness the news of the
horrendous attacks
which on easter sunday have brought
sadness
and pain to some churches
and other places in sri lanka
i would like to express my heartfelt
closeness
to the christian community
which was attacked while gathered in
prayer
and to all victims of such a cruel act
of violence
i entrust to the lord all who so
tragically died
and i pray for the wounded and all those
who are suffering because of this
dramatic event
let's get back to jamila najmudin
covering the story on the ground
uh jamila um we've heard about
explosions at
churches at hotels in residential areas
did this attack have a clear target
well initially when the attacks did
happen on sunday morning
it took place in three very popular
churches across the island
that is one church with an anthony's
church in capital colombo
uh the san sebastian's church in negambo
just outside the capital
and the zeon church in basically in the
eastern forest so initially what
everybody assumed was that
it was the catholic community which was
sought after during these attacks
but just within a short span of time
then there were also multiple attacks in
star-class hotels in colombo
where foreigners were also targeted uh
so the exact motive behind these attacks
are yet to be revealed
this is something that we already know
the worst violence in sri lanka since
the end of the civil war ten years ago
what can you tell us about the threats
facing the country at the moment
well basically um when the war ended in
2009
uh we uh we were getting back to normal
this is the 10th year since the end of
the war uh
in fact in may we will be celebrating 10
years
since the war ended um we were getting
back on track uh where the security
level was also
it was also minimized to a great extent
uh but with these attacks today uh
security has been leased up to the
maximum and it is likely to stay
like that at least for the coming weeks
only seven percent of sri lanka's
population is christian
they were of course at the center of
these attacks even if they weren't the
only target
have there been other attacks against
their this religious minority
in the past briefly if you can
yes there has been attacks against the
minorities in the past for example on
palm sunday last week
there was an attack at the methodist
church in anuradhapura which is
in the central coming and then
just a few months ago there were also
attacks in beginner against the minority
muslims
but the government was successful in uh
providing uh
uh safeguarding these minorities
so this attack comes as a total surprise
to all the minorities as well
jamila najmudin thank you very much
thank you a short while ago i spoke to
asanga
abeyaguna sekira head of the institute
of national security studies in colombo
sri lanka
he was in one of the hotels in sri
lanka's capital
that were targeted in today's attacks he
told us about what he witnessed
it was in the shangri-la hotel and so
there was at 8 30
5 the first uh i mean the initial blast
went off and then
i was on my way down to the breakfast
area so that's where it happened but
so the table won the breakfast area
where all the people were
having breakfast and most of them
celebrating the easter
and um so there was a lot of foreigners
and
there's so many victims from that
and i witnessed uh most of them and
actually the military barack said that
the military defense
the headquarters was right next to the
shangri-la hotel and you could see uh
amazingly
there was a lot of assistance coming
from the military and who was running in
while we were walking out of the
building they were mentally running into
assistant
and so many casualties so um
in there and uh there were
simultaneously uh there was uh
uh bombs from uh like everywhere like
seven seven other bombs from uh
uh in different different places in uh
sri lanka
and um from 2017 in march we've been uh
uh we'll be sort of highlighting the uh
our institute has been uh
national secretaries have been
highlighting this there is a serious
threat on the
violent extremist uh groups uh there are
there are so many
groups who are uh involved in sri lanka
and there could be a threat
uh serious significant sector coming
into sri lanka
and um and this sort of um i mean uh if
you take the uh
the targeted attacks in the san antonio
one of the uh most popular churches were
for the christians to come even from the
villages they
come in there and you could see many
victims uh
from that church attack and many other
uh churches
that was asanga abeyaguna sekira head of
the institute of national security
studies in colombo sri lanka he spoke to
us earlier by phone
let me quickly bring you up to speed on
the story we've been following for you
this hour
officials now say at least 207 people
have been killed and hundreds injured
in explosions at churches and hotels in
sri lanka
the first seven explosions hit colombo
as well as the town of negombo
and batikaloa in the east of the country
a major church
in colombo was among the buildings hit
other targets were five-star hotels
the defense minister says seven suspects
have been arrested
for more analysis let's bring in dw
sonya falnikar
in our studio in delhi sonia people
around the world are following events in
sri lanka what's been the reaction so
far in india and other countries in the
region
so well there's really been um a flood
of statements here across the asian
subcontinent
uh across the indian subcontinent really
condemning these attacks now here in
india of course which is a neighbor of
sri lanka's and a crucial ally
uh prime minister narendra modi has you
know issued a press release
he's also tweeted saying there is no
place for barbarism in our region
he he says he strongly condemns the
blast he said india stands in solidarity
with sri lanka
india's foreign minister sushma swaraj
says you know she's been in touch with
the indian high commission
in colombo she says she's monitoring the
situation very closely
her ministry has also tweeted helplines
for indian nationals
who are trapped in sri lanka
this incident recalls other attacks
we've seen in recent years in the region
in 2016 75 people were killed in an
easter sunday bombing targeting
christians in lahore pakistan
what parallels are there between these
incidents
well i have to say that so far really no
group has really claimed responsibility
for these attacks
in sri lanka and so i think we know very
little at this point about
who was really behind that what the
motive was um in terms of parallels i
mean you know the
the indian subcontinent is really no
stranger to to terror attacks
closer home in india if you remember
back in mumbai in 2008 we had
a terrorist attack but in you know
across
multiple sites in the financial capital
but but as far as parallels go i think
um we can say that you know all these
attacks have been very unexpected in
that they have taken authorities by
surprise
uh they have seemed to be very well
coordinated and well planned that was
the case in mumbai too
uh these attacks have also claimed very
a very high debt toll in mumbai if you
remember
in 2008 174 people died
so yeah there are certainly uh parallels
in that sense but i think if you look at
sri lanka in the context there we have
to remember that there has been really a
major
you know a lull in major violence really
since the end of the civil war in sri
lanka in 2009
now there has been some sporadic
violence between members
of the majority buddhist sinali's
community and
the muslim minority in sri lanka so much
so that last year last march sri lanka
did
you know impose um an emergency um
because of clashes between between the
the buddhist minority
but i think it's really safe to say that
since the end of the civil war since the
defeat of the tamil tigers in 2009
we really haven't seen an incident of
this kind in sri lanka
sonia falnikar thank you for your
analysis